tensions between china and taiwan at an
all-time high we need to fly our planes
in force through china's air defense
zone our best opportunity to deter
china is by arming taiwan and arming
ourselves now before they think about
launching an invasion so are you saying
that the united states would come to
taiwan's defense if china attacked yes
we have a commitment should the united
states use military force to deter china
from invading taiwan that was the
subject of this month's soho forum
debate which took place in front of a
full house at the sheen center in
downtown manhattan william galston a
senior fellow at the brookings
institution and a policy advisor to
president bill clinton defended the
resolution he argued that the u.s should
use all the tools at its disposal to
deter foreign powers from engaging in
conflict with their neighbors with the
ultimate goal of preventing an outright
war such as the one we are witnessing in
europe peter van buren who spent 24
years working as a diplomat for the
united states state department took the
negative he argued that americans rarely
have the context or understanding to
intervene productively in foreign
conflicts and that more often than not
what looks like deterrence to one party
looks like provocation to the other the
debate was moderated by soho forum
director gene epstein
the
resolution reads the u.s should use its
military power to deter china from
invading taiwan
defending the resolution william galston
william please come to the stage
[Applause]
opposing the revolution peter van buren
peter please come to the stage
[Applause]
william galston you're going to take the
podium and you have 15 minutes to defend
the resolution jane please close the
voting thank you
well it's great to be here uh
i already know that i'm not at the
apollo theater
more more thank
you it catches up to you
for me this is
an away game
i am not now nor have i ever been a
libertarian
on the other hand i'm not a
neoconservative either
i am not repeat not
out to remake the world
and i'm not out to start any wars
the resolution is not about starting
wars it's about preventing them
and i think that is very important
having said that
i have a hard
job my job
is to persuade you
to act now or that the united states
should act now
to prevent something that hasn't
happened
from happening
it's not the same thing as responding to
something that has happened for example
ukraine
right ukraine is an example of what i'll
call failed deterrence
whatever we were doing
it did nothing to prevent a terrible war
and i think everybody can see
what not preventing a war looks like
it's horrible
right and the argument for doing what we
can
to prevent something horrible is it
seems to me
the moral core of the proposition before
us
but we're not simply talking about
morality
let me give you a one minute history of
the past 80 years
japanese attacked pearl harbor
hitler
who could have stayed out of it at least
with regard to the united states
immediately or quickly declares war on
the united states we have two enemies
on the eastern front and the western
front
the war ends
total triumph
two years later it becomes clear that we
have one big enemy
and we spent
the next four days confronting that one
big enemy
after the fall of the berlin wall the
collapse of communism
we had or thought we had
no enemies at all
and now it is absolutely clear that we
have two big enemies again so we are
facing the same situation that we faced
80 years ago
except we're not at war with them
yet
so we have a situation we haven't faced
in 80 years how are we going to respond
to it
how should we respond to it
should we do what we did after world war
one
or should we do in a different way
appropriate to our circumstances
what we did after world
war
ii
i know what my choice is
i think the years after world war ii
worked out a whole lot better than the
years after world war one and if we play
our cards right we can prevent world war
iii
let me tell you how i think about the
proposition before us
i've noticed something
about foreign policy
and that is
it makes sense to listen carefully
to what leaders are saying
vladimir putin spent
more than a decade telling the world
that he didn't believe that ukraine was
a country
uh it had no right to exist it was part
of greater russia
it existed as the result of an
historical
accident
i remember how amazed i was when i sat
down and actually read those speeches
that putin gave and then a very long
article that he wrote just last july
right
he made his position absolutely clear
but nobody believed him
indeed when the u.s intelligence
services in november of last year
started telling anyone who would listen
that putin was winding up to wage war
against ukraine
we couldn't get anybody in europe to
believe us with the exception of the
ukrainians and even the ukrainians were
a hard sell and president zielenski
uh
was in partial denial up until a very
short period before the war now why do i
mention this
for a simple reason
it made sense to listen what hitler to
what hitler was saying it made sense to
listen to what putin was saying and it
makes sense to listen to what xi jinping
is saying
and he has made it absolutely clear
that he intends to re-unify
china as he puts it that is to say
amalgamate taiwan into
greater china
on his watch
now we don't know how long his watch is
going to be
now that he has made himself president
for life but he's not a young man he's
not getting any younger and his speeches
which if i'd had time i would quote to
you make it absolutely clear that yes he
would like
taiwan to fall into his hand the way a
ripe apple falls from a tree but he's
not counting on that
and he is preparing his country
for an unpeaceful
reunification with china
that's not all he's preparing them
before
he is preparing them for an era of naval
dominance in the world
and he is preparing his people for the
glorious moment when china replaces the
united states as the world's dominant
power
and as the writer of the rules that the
rest of the world must adhere to
so
i'm sorry how much time do i have left
10 minutes
good
so that raises the question that is now
before us
should the united states use its power
to deter or to do its best to deter
uh china from attacking taiwan
to prevent
another terrible war like the one we are
now seeing
and i think there are a number of
reasons to say yes
uh
one has to do with one of the
fundamental principles of the post-war
era the principle of sovereignty
independence and territorial integrity
of countries
not to be changed by force but only
through consent the principle that is
being violated every minute of every day
and we can watch it being violated
on television now you may say well
that's okay
taiwan isn't really a country
well that's what putin said about
ukraine and he offered many of the same
reasons that she does
but one of the core propositions
that i am resting my case on
is that certain groups of people and
bodies of territory may not begin as
countries
but they can become countries
taiwan i want to argue has become a
sovereign and independent country
whose integrity and independence is
worth defending if we can
i will also mention the fact that taiwan
which began as an autocracy
has evolved into
a democracy a healthy thriving
multi-party democracy
has it always been that way
but it is definitely that way now
that also makes it worth defending if we
can
there are concrete american interests at
stake as well
taiwan
controls
nearly 25 percent
of the semiconductor production capacity
of the world and according to the boston
consulting group
in a report issued in december
it is responsible for fully
92.
of
advanced chip manufacturer in the
world
it is a place therefore of enormous
strategic
significance
semiconductor chips
are the oil of the 21st century economy
and we've already seen what happens when
those chips become scarce
products that depend
on chips
can no longer be made in sufficient
quantities
like automobiles which now have between
500 and 1000 semiconductor chips per car
a a chinese takeover of taiwan
would in effect
turn china into the opec of
semiconductor chips
i would submit that is not in the
national interest
the a chinese takeover of taiwan would
in addition affect the calculus of our
allies throughout asia
whether we like it or not
countries
bend
to the will of what they regard as the
superior power in their region
and when that power shifts
countries that have been with us a vital
part of american alliance
the american alliance throughout asia
for decades will suddenly find reasons
not to be with us
third and concretely
the well-being
of an incredibly important ally and
partner namely japan is at stake
i will take a minute to remove to read a
portion
of an analysis from the chinese air
command
and it it says this as soon as taiwan is
reunified with mainland china
japan's maritime lines of communication
will fall completely
within the striking range of chinese
fighters and bombers our analysis shows
that by using blockades
if we can reduce japan's raw imports by
15 to 20 percent it will be a heavy blow
to to japan's economy
after imports have been reduced by 30
percent
japan's economic activity and war-making
potential will be basically destroyed
after imports have been reduced by 50
percent
its national economy and war-making
capacity will collapse completely
blockades can even create famine within
the japanese islands
all of those chinese capacities and the
ability to turn them into reality would
be triggered by the loss of taiwan
and if you don't believe what i'm saying
talk to any japanese diplomat that is
their number one worry in the world
stage
we should deter if we can
can we
yes we can in two ways
number one
by
executing what's known as the porcupine
strategy to help taiwan defend itself
uh
the porcupine is not a particularly
strong article a animal it's certainly
not a particularly fast animal
but it knows how to defend itself
by making things very painful for any
would-be aggressor
if we give taiwan what we should have
given
the ukrainians a long time ago
namely the capacity to defend themselves
against bombers
against missiles
and against ships particularly ship
assault ships that carry troops across
the
across the straits to land on taiwan's
beaches
we can probably
we can probably allow taiwan
to protect itself
much better against a potential chinese
assault than we can right now
second
everything depends on the balance of
naval forces
between china and the united states the
united states has allowed its navy to
wither at precisely the point when the
chinese have decided to become the
world's greatest maritime
power that is not written in the stars
it is a policy choice and i submit it is
a policy choice that we can make
in conclusion
deterrence is costly
and in some cases risky
however
the costs of not determining deterring
armed conflict are even hard or even
higher and the dangers
are even greater
if we had helped
ukraine
defend itself
if we had taken action to deter what is
now happening before our very eyes i
submit to you the chances that it would
be happening would have been greatly
reduced
why not use the same strategy for taiwan
thank you very much
[Applause]
speaking for the negative uh peter van
duren take it away peter
oh sorry about that
thank you
no
i've spent my whole life listening to
people talk about wars we weren't going
to have and then we had i've listened my
whole life in 24 years as a state
department diplomat watching enemies
disappear so that new enemies would come
and take their place i drank champagne
on government time on government salary
when the wall came down and history
ended and then i found myself once again
looking at a new department of
anti-terrorism i served a year in iraq i
saw dead bodies in ditches that did not
achieve the freedom we had promised them
and now
i have to hear about another enemy that
we're going to deter that's going to end
up taking lives no one in this room
in their lives has spent more than a
handful of years without the united
states being at war somewhere or
invading somewhere or having a police
action or a military intervention or
helping the contras or helping the
terrorists or helping the
anti-terrorists fill in the blanks my
life and your life has been one of
continuous warfare in the united states
stretching from central america
throughout the middle east and now what
do we want to do we want to revisit asia
as if the war in vietnam laos cambodia
and parts of thailand was not sufficient
enough what if the united states simply
walked away and left asia and other
parts of the world alone
would it really be any worse
the u.s should not use its military
power to deter china from invading
taiwan it is unnecessary
and is more likely to provoke a war than
to stop one
in addition porcupines are far too cute
to use in that uh particular analogy i
would have gone with something like a
warthog or the along those lines
the current strategy of strategic
ambiguity vis-a-vis taiwan and china
serves two very important goals american
goals world goals it keeps the peace
and it allows for a productive
trilateral plus plus relationship
among china taiwan the united states and
the other countries in asia and it's
important always to conclude all of the
participants uh i was very uh enlivened
to hear that nick is uh
in favor of uh butts and three ways in
reason magazine because this arrangement
in asia is not simply china and the
united states or china and taiwan the
united states is an active player and we
need to keep all three participants
on the ground
as far as deterrence being unnecessary i
note that during the entire 73-year
existence of taiwan the mainland has not
invaded despite changes in leadership as
dramatic as mao to deng xiaoping to xi
the mainland has not invaded despite
taiwan changing from a military
dictatorship well supported by the
united states by the way to a democracy
the mainland has not invaded despite
global changes including the korean and
the vietnam wars development of nuclear
weapons by china the fall of the soviet
union and donald trump the mainland has
not invaded the u.s posture has varied
from garrosing the island of taiwan to
strategic ambiguity to sending special
forces there which are present currently
and the mainland has simply not invaded
the chinese military has gone from
peasants with rifles to the blue water
navy professor gulstan uh is so enamored
with backed by icbms and yet the
mainland has not invaded
china has gone from the agrarian
isolation of the cultural revolution
to a fully integrated if not in fact
essential part of the industrialized
global economy in the mainland
has not invaded putin got away with most
of what he was trying to do already in
the ukraine and the mainland has not
invaded that stop this is not going to
change in our lifetimes and there's
really not much more to say you're left
with the question of well what will
cause all this to change and my answer
is not a whole lot the ball keeps
bouncing history remains i'll be at the
bar thank you heaven
i have more time
you laugh
but
in fact a couple of important points
here and by the way those of you who are
interested in fact checking me
if you go to my website which is
wementwell.com
i have a text of what a rough text of
what i'm doing tonight and all of the
facts that i'm listing are all linked
there and so you'll be able to fact
check me in real time
now that business about leaving the
world alone deterrence is is very much a
funny word because what looks like
deterrence from one side
such as forward deploying an aircraft
carrier might indeed look like
provocation from the other side do we
have that slide please
what looks like deterrence against uh
american hemoglobin in asia over flights
might in fact look like provocation from
the other side you'll be reading or have
read an awful lot
about chinese air incursions so i
thought i would come up with a map
that showed you these air defense
interdiction zones that you hear about
being violated all the time you'll
notice that the yellow one that taiwan
has created for itself actually
physically overlaps mainland china and
so that chinese jets sitting on their
own runways are in fact in violation of
that be careful when you read the
newspaper or the magazines and see
something about provocation
some of you are big fans i'm sure of
disputed islands i don't want to leave
you out up there in the balcony and for
those of you that are fans of disputed
islands i'll point out that little blip
in the green line that's japan's own uh
area of air defense interdiction and you
notice it makes a little loop
just to the
east of taiwan that's a disputed island
that we just don't want to talk about
because it's the taiwanese and the
japanese who are kind of fussing
over that one we don't even want to get
into the islands that are between korea
and japan so there's an awful lot of
what we call provocation going on in
east asia we only seem to want to talk
about the chinese side
there's also more importantly very
little need for deterrence that many
including professor gulstan uh advocate
for this evening the chinese on both
sides of the strait understand that
there is much to be gained from economic
ties and political ambiguity
and a much greater risk in invasion that
would do little more than tidy up some
of the leftovers of the cold war from
1949
but let's talk about deterrence that's
what we're asking for here let's talk
about what deterrence looks like when
you view it through the lens of
provocation
china has exactly four overseas bases
there's a small logistics operation in
djibouti africa
a listening post on the great cocoa
island which by the way is not in the
bahamas it's near
burma
a navy outpost in gwadar which is
somewhere near pakistan and of course a
military outpost
and forgive my pronunciation in gordo
paddock
tajikistan i'm sure a lot of people who
consider themselves well informed on
this subject would have a hard time
naming more than one of those places in
contrast throughout the world the united
states maintained
750 bases
a few less now that the afghan adventure
is over but these include formal
facilities in eight different asian
nations 50 000 troops in japan 24 000 in
south korea alone the u.s maintained
troops on taiwan up until 1979 and
currently has special forces there in
what we'll euphemistically call training
missions
that many of those military bases
predate the people's republic of china
and in fact the fact that they were set
up to deter there's our word again in
the porcupine strategy to deter the
soviet union and of course the soviet
union is gone
but the bases are still there leaving
open the question of what their purpose
really really is
as i said be careful with language the
incursions into air space which many
people have raised as red alerts are
actually simply a fun
a foundation of creative map making
there is no such thing as an air defense
interdiction zone in international law
or practice it's simply something that
you draw around yourself for example at
the reception tonight if you really
think that i'm kind of a pain in the
neck and you want to draw a distinction
you can put a zone around yourself and i
will promise not to violate that
at various points in history american
bases overseas including in asian
countries have stored nuclear weapons
and some may do so even today
forward-deployed u.s warships are
believed to contain nuclear weapons the
ohio class and soon virginia-class
submarines off china's coasts east with
20 ballistic missiles almost certainly
contain nuclear weapons and no matter if
those don't matter or aren't available
flights direct from the united states
mainland only take a few hours pretend
now you're from mars
and just visiting soho
and tell me which side seems provoking
and which side seems deterring
the key element
of strategic ambiguity which is
enshrined in the 1979 taiwan relations
act
is in fact
a better idea than the strategic clarity
that i think professor galston and those
who argue for more deterrence are
talking about the more specific your
response is ahead of time such as
article 5 the more your hands are tied
remember deterrence did work in ukraine
for russia stop the united states
now let's talk about some reasons why
japan or sorry china sorry wrong war um
china is not intending to go china has
188 billion dollars worth of investment
in the united states the value of
cross-straight trade between china and
taiwan
149 billion dollars china is the second
largest holder of foreign u.s bonds they
are literally betting the shop on this
relationship holding up over the long
run there's an awful lot of money
professor galston
mentioned rhetoric out of china
particularly some of
president xi's type of thing and you
know the rhetoric from china has not
changed from mao until xi it essentially
talks about the historic inevitability
of a single china and in china when you
talk with the chinese diplomats and i've
been assigned to both
china big china we used to call it hong
kong and also in taiwan you hear it from
chinese diplomats all the time we deal
in hundreds of years thousands of years
and inevitably they're going to throw a
four character phrase at you that you
won't understand that means it's going
to be a long time till this all happens
particularly the rhetoric that professor
galston referred to um and i he probably
reads it uh in in english which has a
different spin to it oftentimes
is often coming in the political season
which takes place in october there's a
whole series of political holidays the
founding of the pr3 takes place on
october 1st taiwan celebrates its
national day on october 10th and both
countries celebrate the 1911 shihai
revolution rebellion there which set off
the process that created both china's
ultimately and this is always a great
time for rhetoric and so keep in mind
when you're looking at a piece of
rhetoric and you decided you might want
to get scared reading it see if it
didn't come from one of these october
events and if it did turn the dial from
11 down to a comfortable six and
participate as our comedian said in some
of those more exotic coveted cures
the goal here
that's the only thing that gets us gets
a cheer out of people
philosophically chinese leaders have for
thousands of years believed in
historical cycles they waited close to
300 years to end the foreign qing
dynasty they waited out britain for
hundreds of years for the peaceful
return of hong kong
such things come up in conversation with
their diplomats all the times often as
you talk about weather
the chinese are patient people and they
believe in historical cycles
i don't think any of us will ever live
to see a united china but i can
guarantee you none of us will ever live
to see a chinese invasion of taiwan
i have to end with a quote from sun tzu
one waits to win thank you
[Applause]
built austin five minutes for rebuttal
you can take the take the podium if you
want or you wait your choice let's do it
take it from the take it from the podium
shot sounds good yeah
well
i had a lot thrown at me
so let me throw some of it back
first of all
i was i was careful in what i said but
also in what i did not say you know and
i did not once to the best of my
knowledge invoke
you know a
violation of taiwan's airspace
you know as
as a piece of evidence to prove anything
nor i note for the record
did i call for
an explicit end to the policy of
strategic ambiguity
strategic ambiguity can be part of a
deterrence strategy
and i think in that context it has much
to commend it so let us dispose as not
germaine to this particular debate those
though those two
allegations
now
then there are then there are issues
of
logic
consider the proposition
mainland china
has not
invaded taiwan
and therefore it won't
what that is not exactly a syllogism i
think we can both agree
right because an equally valid syllogism
would be
as late as
february of this year
russia hasn't invaded ukraine
and therefore it won't
that would have been a fine argument in
february at least it wasn't obviously
false
but it's obviously false now
that brings us i think to the nub of the
matter
and that is that the two of us don't
even have a factual dispute
we have a predictive
dispute
you don't believe
that china
will ever invade taiwan at least not in
our lifetime if i understood you
correctly
and i believe something different
i believe something different
uh
based in part not just on what the
political leaders are saying in
some octobers it's not every october
some octobers and particularly octobers
divided in years divided by five
i am also taking into account chinese
military documents
uh and i must add my frequent contacts
with chinese officials
whose tone on this question has changed
very fundamentally in just the past five
years
uh
this is not
if i can vary the asian analogy just
slightly this is not kabuki theater
there has been a huge change in china
which students of china have
chronicled particularly since xi jinping
came to power
chinese diplomacy has been more
aggressive chinese aims have become more
explicit more firmly stated
and there has been an enormous military
buildup in china how much more time do i
have jane
i'm sorry one minute thank you
and
i would ask you the following question
if we had helped ukraine defend itself
and it turned out
200 years later that russia never had
any attention to attacking ukraine
okay
we were frightened with false fire
as shakespeare said
if we help
taiwan defend itself
and also help defend freedom of the seas
with a stronger navy
i think the harm done
is modest compared to the harm prevented
if the prediction that underlies my side
of the case turns out to be true thank
you
[Applause]
i apologize about the defense zones i
brought that up only because it's a very
common theme in most of the things that
people are reading so please accept my
apology
on that taiwan is not the ukraine and
you can't simply pick that out and so
draw analogies only because the ukraine
invasion happened to happen at the same
time we're holding this forum if the
ukrainian invasion uh did not happen we
wouldn't be talking about the ukraine
because that situation russia has
nothing in common with what's going on
in east asia um those of you come to the
reception i'll be happy to trap you in a
corner and explain that at great great
length um the why now problem is i think
where this all comes down to because
we're left with this idea that as the
professor stated there about this
predictive part of it and you know the
only point of studying history is for
its predictive value the lessons that
you learn there but you're left with
that question well why now why would
china invade right now would they do
that because there's simply far too much
money being passed back and forth across
the uh the taiwan straits would they do
that right now because they just are
really really tired of the 2.68 million
visits a year that occur between taiwan
and and china are would they do it right
now the invasion because there are 25
000 mainland students studying on taiwan
right now would they do it because there
are nine airlines flying non-stop
flights between taiwan and the mainland
they're not flying just from taipei to
beijing they're flying from smaller
cities in taiwan to even smaller cities
because of the enormous number of family
visits that are taking place would they
do it because president xi would like to
risk his entire government in fact the
entire political structure of mainland
china on an amphibious invasion of
taiwan arguably the most difficult
military operation that anyone could
could undertake
why now
i was in taiwan in 1989
when we asked the why now question
taiwan was emerging as a democracy and
there were a there was a taiwan
independence policy party
looking to take some seats in the
legislature and as i'm sure you're all
aware declaring independence formally is
one of those red lines in the taiwan
strait area and many of us at the
american institute in taiwan are pretend
embassy there we're fearful that the
result of this independence party taking
seats in the legislature might be
that invasion that some have predicted
we waited we worried we put some food
away
and what happened was
that the marketplaces started flooding
with goods from the mainland the
invasion was certainly there but it was
economic not military the number of
reasons that china would not invade
taiwan is so voluminous that it's very
very difficult to imagine any one reason
why they would if all you can point to
is president a line in president xi
speech by the way he said in his
lifetime they would begin the process of
unification or something along those
lines it was far from definitive because
this is not a situation where you make
definitive statements and that's why
strategic ambiguity the way that the
united states should step back and allow
the two chinas to continue their
commerce their social their intellectual
interactions is something that has
worked that something will continue to
work and i stand here with great
confidence predicting that none of us
will ever see fisticuffs across the
taiwan strait thank you
[Applause]
thank you to the two debaters we now get
to the q a part of the evening i take it
we have microphones on the side and i
trust we have microphones on the balcony
yes so that people in the balcony can
ask questions as well
but i'm going to begin
by taking moderator's prerogative to ask
a couple of questions of the debaters
but even before i do that i'd like to
invite them to ask each other a question
you can exercise that option at any time
would you i would either you like to ask
the other a question or would you like
to waive that and wait for audience
questions to materialize bill you want
to wait or you want to i think the
audience is good yeah good yeah yeah
make sure you have the microphone okay
wait for the audience uh you want to ask
a question the audience has been very
patient and i
i here i
uh abandoned my my question asking
prerogative for now well you don't know
necessarily foreign
can you can re you can you can abandon
that abandonment at any time bill if you
if you feel that you should uh but i
want to ask a couple of questions just
to just to rile you guys up i believe uh
peter van buren that i heard you state
at the outset
a rather radical position that uh you
would be willing to defend not not just
this uh what did you call it uh
simulator forgive me uh strategic
ambiguity but as a as a way of uh
pursuing policy but that you would just
as soon see the u.s completely pivot out
of uh asia uh and do do you think that
would be even a better solution well i
have to begin by saying it's it's
actually an impossible thing it's it's
it's saying porcupines are going to fly
it's simply not going to happen yeah and
so i offer it more as a rhetoric
would you say
would you have said in 1986 that the
soviet union is not going to fall don't
be ridiculous would you have said that
in 1986 uh i was in junior high school
okay then i waved i waved the question
but a lot of people were saying in 1986
the idea that the soviet union would
collapse is ridiculous in 1850 the end
of slavery don't be silly but anyway
that aside could you just answer the
questions to whether it's possible
without without hesitation is that less
is is more that the united states
interventions overseas and we're getting
off the topic here but this includes
taiwan um the united states
interventions have caused far more harm
than good literal harm in terms of
bodies piled up here and there
but also political harm we've we've
mucked around in places and caused
trouble i think taiwan and china are
both extremely skillful diplomats i
think they know what their interests are
i think they know where their soft spots
are and i think the more that we stand
back and allow them to conduct their
their relations with one another without
us necessarily leaning over everyone's
shoulder um while standing back if if
somebody needs to uh ask us a question i
think would be a more productive policy
in the long run
even including withdrawal from japan
from korea getting out of asia all
together well again i mean those are
those are just simply impossible things
and i think the other thing to keep in
mind is that the forces in japan and
korea are there for other reasons uh the
debate on north korea i think would go a
different way okay i think do you want
to comment on that bill you want to
put over and make sure you have your
microphone bill in your hand do you want
to comment on that answer do you want to
wave comment
uh
i can either wave comment or get into a
very long discussion
of comparing the results of america's
getting involved to the results of
america's not getting involved which is
why i mentioned the world war one
aftermath versus the world war ii
aftermath i would submit that staying
out of world affairs between world war
one and world war ii was a disaster for
the world
and it and and it allowed a situation to
develop in which the united states was
dragged into a war that it did not
choose looks like you want to make a
comment you want to take that argument
into the multiple iraq wars as well
you know boy
look let the record show
because it does
that i was an early fervent opponent of
the war
in iraq
but the fact
that one war is bad
or two wars or three wars el salvador
does not prove
okay yes i know i know the litany as
well as you do
and therefore all wars are bad
is that the cool the weights that the
scales seem to be pretty heavy on one
side here uh which are the good ones i
would
i would take
i think that what the united states did
in world war ii more than outweighs all
of the failed wars that you've just
talked about no no man i saw saving
private ryan like 17 times but after
world war ii
which interventions uh are the good ones
we
we prevented a lot of bad things we
prevented a soviet takeover of europe i
think that was a pretty good thing to do
i am not arguing for a policy of war i'm
arguing for a policy of deterrence which
is exactly the strategy that we used for
40 years and it was a damn good thing
that we did
okay uh question i just uh please phrase
your question ask the question don't
have to identify yourself and say to
whom you're addressing the question if
anybody i'd like to address this to both
uh our debaters yeah um should the post
to the microphone as you can please okay
should the united states and its allies
with taiwan's concurrence recognize the
existence of taiwan or should we
continue to pretend it doesn't exist
should we recognize the existence of
taiwan
do you want to take that peter yeah
we should not formally recognize the
existence of taiwan simply because it is
a stated red line
and the advantages of crossing that red
line are so overwhelmingly wiped out by
the disadvantages of crossing that red
line
it's important to note that we treat
taiwan as a country in nearly every
sense of that word absent calling it a
country
it's one of those situations where the
benefits
so outweigh the other side that i can't
responsibly say we should recognize
taiwan do you want to comment bill as it
happens i agree with that answer
completely okay
we go we're getting agreement we don't
we want debate we don't want agreement
uh next question
i have a question to william
we have seen
in
the ukraine
that trying to take over another country
could lead to the situation where russia
could plant a
flag on a huge pile of rubble
and everything else will be done
with that experience
is the risk higher or lower
that
china will take on taiwan
that sir is a very good question
and the honest answer to your question
is i don't know but
let me but let me make a broader point
where i do think i have some evidence on
my side
it is a frequent argument
against
the prediction that war will break out
that it is economically irrational for a
war to break out
history demonstrates that that is not a
good argument
empirically
uh it was a very popular argument during
the edwardian period the decade before
world war one as a matter of fact a man
by the name of norman angel
wrote a book
for which he won the nobel prize in
literature making the argument that
there would be no war in europe because
it is economically irrational for a war
in europe to break out
almost all wars are economically
irrational but somehow
they keep on breaking out
so permit me to doubt
the fact
look
i think that it would be
profoundly
irrational from many economic and
diplomatic standpoints
for china
to use force
to seize taiwan and reintegrate it with
the mainland does that lead me to
believe that china would not do that no
it does not for the aforestated reason
can you comment from you peter oh you
want
if the only thing i had on the table
here was economics i would probably have
to lean a little further towards
professor's answer but in fact there are
so many different reasons why china and
taiwan would not go to war and i i would
stress that one of them that is so
important and it's very very difficult
to to understand
is that these are people that see
themselves as the same people there is
no there's no
inherent animosity about those guys over
there who were different than us
taiwan is is is mostly han chinese they
speak the same language they share the
same history up until 1949
they see the world in the same way they
eat the same foods they look at things
in the same way and there's those 2.68
million
family visits across the straits and so
if it was simply economics france and
germany i think there's more to the the
argument but in the case of china and in
taiwan it's so much richer
that i have to say that the economic
argument while important is just part of
a much bigger and richer picture
next question
uh this is to william galston
the main american interest i heard was
an economic one that its microchip
production capacity is the opec of the
21st century
but just as america has become a more
dominant force in the oil market what is
stopping us from being a more dominant
force in microchips and secondly
we trust china with many supply chains
that we depend on
and we haven't pursued interventions to
prevent it
why this one why now
good question uh
first of all we have become
i have noticed
a lot less trusting
of supply chains including mainland
china than we were for example before
the pandemic
we discovered
uh we we discovered in the pandemic that
we were highly dependent on china for
even the basic medical supplies that we
needed
although reason magazine clearly doesn't
agree with me on this point to try to
reduce the severity of the pandemic
like masks for example i know they're
not popular particularly in this room
but if we were having another debate i
think i would try to persuade you that
there was and continues to be in some
circumstances merit to masquerading
here is the problem
it is a lot easier
to move production
of
of goods such as masks and other basic
medical materials than it is to quickly
change microchip production
and
you know since peter had a slide i have
a visual
okay and
it is a visual from
the business section of today's new york
times
entitled the huge endeavor to produce a
tiny microchip
and it is followed by a very very lucid
explanation
covering these two pages
as to the extraordinary investment
of money and time
uh that it would take to shift the
production chain
of taiwan in the area of microchips to
the united states we're not talking
about a year or two years or three years
and if you don't believe me
listen to the president of intel
corporation who has given very detailed
remarks
on the extraordinary difficulty of
replicating in the united states as a
matter of fact
as a matter of fact a lot of the best
technology in this area has gravitated
to taiwan
and if the chinese were to take it over
obviously i think the pace of
technological advance would slow
uh but it would still be a huge shift
you know it would be like the equivalent
of another country invading texas and
taking over its oil supply it would be a
real game changer
you made one other remark
that suggests that i may not have been
sufficiently clear in my opening remarks
the economics of the situation is very
important but that's not the only thing
that's important
uh there are countries throughout asia
that depend on the united states
for their independence and security
starting with south korea
but also including japan
i quoted from a chinese military manual
on the way they're thinking about taiwan
in relation to japan
and guess what
the japanese are thinking about the
relationship between taiwan and japan in
exactly the same way
which is
why they are scared expletive deleted
of the possibility
that china
would uh
would mount an aggressive war against
taiwan so there are economic reasons
there are diplomatic reasons and there
are military slash strategic reasons for
caring about the future of of taiwan
uh comment peter just on japan i want to
clarify that whereas once it was very
obvious that the united states was
japan's protector um that really is less
and less the case all the time first of
all japan is one of several threshold
nuclear countries in in asia south korea
taiwan as well that have the technology
have the have the ability
to develop nuclear weapons fairly
quickly if they wanted to do that japan
also has been aggressively enlarging its
blue water navy they have several
aircraft carriers right now they're
buying the f-35 from the united states
they're pretty well ready to take care
of themselves that said professor
gaustin and i do agree on south korea
and north korea that's uh that would be
a very dull debate because i think we
find ourselves strictly in agreement
lastly on the idea of of conductor
semiconductors and things like that i
think you could ask the arab nations
very quickly if you could eat an iphone
because that would be ultimately what
would happen in china if somebody has to
produce these things somebody would
next question
uh thank you both for being here
appreciate the civil debate and i have a
question that's directed to both of you
um i know you've obviously stated that
you consider this extremely unlikely but
i still think it's it's hard to say that
it's totally impossible but if china
were to invade taiwan let's say
including an amphibious invasion
uh should the u.s go to war with china
in order to defend taiwan i think the
question is addressing you peter and
bill should follow up answer the
question peter so you're talking about
we just we interrupt this uh this debate
to tell us that there's a shooting war
now in in between taiwan and china
that's a tough one because at that point
my prediction has been proven wrong
and i so i mean i have to concede uh
that that we probably should have uh you
know gone with those porcupines
um
[Laughter]
let me ask can we vote right now
hurry up
let me answer it in a completely
disingenuous way um which is to say that
i think taiwan is in a pretty good
position to defend itself taiwan
currently uh the united states by the
way is one of the provisions of the 1979
taiwan relations act which established
this bizarro world that exists between
the united states and taiwan is that the
united states must sell weapons to
taiwan and taiwan fields the f-16
they're probably going to be looking to
buy the f-35 if we can make that happen
if they can make that happen through
congress and those of you who feel the
israeli lobby is strong way to figure
out what the taiwan lobbyists are
capable of
they also have currently have the
harpoon missile which has a 60 a basic
60 mile radius meaning that they could
hit the top the the chinese ships almost
as if as they're leaving harbor the
taiwan people are also developing their
own anti-ship missile that will have a
range of well over 100 miles which means
they can launch the missile from the
other side of the island and hit the
chinese ships in port
an invasion something like this is so
improbable if you're talking about the
estimates and i'm quoting from the the
pentagon's annual china military power
report
talking about something like 10 times
the number of men who were landed at
normandy would be needed here you're
looking at such an improbable situation
that i'm not going to answer your
question any further
uh bill you want to comment
if
if this event
were to occur
uh
it would probably be too late to do
anything about it which is why i am so
interested in the strategy of deterrence
i want to say for the fifth time
yet
i am what i'm talking about tonight
is not war
it's war prevention
uh and we have to acknowledge the fact
that
china has some some strategic advantages
in the region that the united states
despite its best efforts
cannot replicate
as every military strategist going back
for thousands of years will tell you
geography matters
and
you know the
the problems of american force
projection
you know across thousands of miles
uh
dwarf
the sorts of difficulties that the
chinese
would have
and so
deciding to go to war
is not it can be in part a moral
question but it's also a very practical
question
of but going to war when you start out
at a systemic disadvantage
is something that is pretty hard to
justify it would do it would depend on
the facts of the case
but i'm tempted to end where i began
that is if war would
were to break out tonight it would be
much too late to do anything about it
unless
and i'm not recommending this
unless we're willing to go all the way
up the escalation ladder yes
i am not willing to do that
in the same way that i am not willing to
go up the escalation ladder with with
regard to ukraine
uh and if vladimir putin is serious i
hope to god he isn't
you know about rattling the nuclear
saber
then he has what the experts call threat
dominance
that is he's willing to do something the
other side namely us isn't and therefore
he wins in the long run
next question
hi uh hi my questions
hi my uh question is mostly for william
and but peter if you want to comment i'd
be interested to hear your comment too
um
we hear a lot about deterring china but
i'm also curious how much we need to
deter taiwan from declaring independence
and if something like
getting serious about giving taiwan
really strong defense capabilities would
make it more likely for them to declare
independence because they might think
they could fight off
a chinese invasion and what the risks
are there
bill he wants you to answer first so go
ahead bill galston
uh
now i do not want to contradict myself
and therefore i will not say that it's
that because it would be irrational for
the taiwanese to declare independence
therefore they never would they might
but my interpretation of the past three
decades of political history in taiwan
is that they've come to understand
pretty well the downside of declaring
independence and the upside of
preserving this somewhat ambiguous
diplomatic and international status
i suspect that if the taiwanese declared
independence it would be over american
protests i bet on that
which is not
the way you want to take a step that the
other side namely china will regard as
something between a provocation and the
crossing of a red line that justifies a
military response
i absolutely agree when i was in in
taiwan ait we practiced what we called
among ourselves rhetoric
management
to make sure that the words that were
coming out of our colleagues on the
taiwan side were not
inching closer and closer to these red
lines and i think every politician every
media person in taiwan understands that
speaking openly of independence would be
the equivalent of
i don't know the president of the united
states using the n-word on on tv
it is just that level of understanding
that i don't think you'll ever see that
happen
next question
in recent events i think if you think of
china you think of hong kong and the
suppression there and also the treatment
of the weakers internally
um that might just be availability bias
but i would ask each of you uh do those
events in recent history uh change how
you think about this issue or the
likelihood that they would invade
peter
china is not a democracy uh nobody's
pretending that that it is i cut off my
great ponytail a long time ago um chai
want china
will exercise its power in hong kong the
same way it exercises it in shanghai or
in tiananmen square and so the things
you're talking about are not surprising
at all to say though that somehow that
leads to an invasion of taiwan with all
the consequences we've talked about i i
don't see that connection happen
i know there is
something of a disagreement on stage
about the weight to be placed on
statements by president xi
but in a speech that he gave last year
before certain unfortunate events in
hong kong
he said that if there were a
reunification
of taiwan and the mainland it would be
under the principle of one nation two
systems i believe we've heard that
before
and uh i do think that at the very least
what has happened in hong kong is
relevant to the question of how
seriously we should take that sort of
promise which in my judgment is not at
all
the chinese communist party
is not prepared to tolerate any
alternative to itself and we shouldn't
fool ourselves about that
um you advocate for preemptively arming
taiwan as a means to potentially deter
attacks from china however it seems to
me in the wake of the ukraine war the
u.s and nato has already sent the signal
to strong men that if they invade
southern democratic states we will step
up provide arms enclosed sanctions etc
so given that
why
the risk of being preemptive since we've
already sent that signal
another very good question i have to
commend the soho forum
you know i can assure you i am
the sole democrat writing a weekly
column for the wall street journal and i
just wish my incoming from that gig were
anything like the quality of the
questions tonight i really do so also
agreed yeah
uh
you've given one
plausible interpretation of recent
events it's not an interpretation
that i share or that is widely shared
i think the signal the signal we sent
was that we weren't prepared to do
what was necessary
you know to try you know to do
everything we could to deter the russian
invasion before it came
uh
we had a lot of warning
right we had events in georgia
we had the seizure of crimea crimea
we had the famous little green men
invasion of the donbass
and we did next to nothing in response
and i think that mr putin drew some
conclusions from that that now that may
have encouraged him to do what he did it
is also the case
that until time was very short
we did something to help the ukrainians
defend themselves
but much less than we now have to do
because we're racing to catch up after
the fact because we didn't do what we
should have done a long time ago and
really give them a credible defense
deterrent which they lacked
and they've done amazingly well
given what they had to work with
but imagine how much better they will be
able to do if they had pre-positioned
military stockpiles which we could have
given them
uh comment from you peter
okay yeah um next question
hi
i agree with peter that is absolutely
impossible to invade the taiwan by
ambition by with an amphibious assault
now
most of us are aware of what's going on
in china
they're having a housing bubble that's
going to burst evergreen
300 billion in debt they're going to
default
high-speed transit completely overbuilt
their show projects they're losing 400
million 400 hundred billion excuse me
room buys each every day they're also
defaulting
300 million people are unemployed that's
like the entire united states are
employed
and they have these crazy zero culvert
lockdowns in
and even writing it's a good thing ccp
has strict gun control laws now given
these concerns can i ally
your fear that
pain is only having
political theater with his religion
talks besides he's also getting of being
voted in the second is there is there a
question in the sr yes can i
can i analyze your fears but that's with
the knowledge
yes i think those are good points okay
yeah well hey thank you and uh uh bill
you want to comment or you want to
uh
i guess this will count as a point of
disagreement uh because you did not
you did not allay my fears
among other things
dictators who have problems at home
frequently turn to oversee oversea
events and adventures in order to change
the subject and to rally the rally of
the population and so
the fact that the chinese may and i
underscore may be running into economic
difficulty although i can tell you
economists are disagreeing on that score
uh i think is not a not a reason to
discount uh the possibility of military
adventurism i would only suggest that
committing economic suicide over an
invasion of taiwan is a very poor answer
to economic problems at home
well
i didn't i didn't say it was an answer
to the economic problems i said that it
could be part of an answer political
answer to the political problems that
flow from economic problems that would
exclude the fact that it would cause
economic aversion of economic suicide
number one and number two it assumes
that the excursion into taiwan works
that the chinese the pla is not defeated
on the beaches that she is able to
retain power after a failed invasion so
i think it's just too risky now okay
okay strike west is a different story oh
okay i i'm i'm afraid we're out of time
for the questions uh both gentlemen will
be coming to the party afterwards so you
can call them then we we want to go to
the summation portion of the evening uh
thanks for all your very good questions
bill galston you have five minutes to
summarize do you want to take the podium
to summarize you want to do from there
i can
i can do it from here
i can do it from here i think that will
save a little bit of time
yeah i just i'm not going to take five
minutes because i think the principal
lines of disagreement have become
quite clear
i want to stress now for the sixth time
that the proposition on the table is not
about starting the war starting a war
it's about preventing law that's what
deterrence means
and
deterrence
doesn't mean certainty
what it means is planting uh what it
means is planting a doubt
in the minds of potential aggressor of
sufficient magnitude
to influence that aggressor's potential
aggressors judgment that is the kind of
deterrence that i'm talking about
i am not talking about a radical change
in american policy such as the
abandonment of the policy of strategic
ambiguity
uh i am however arguing
that
what
may very well be economically irrational
could have a political rationale
sufficiently weighty to override the
economic downside which could be a
temporary economic downside or
potentially a more than temporary or
should i say more than transitory
economic downside
i believe that
we can do this
uh
at a relatively modest cost not nothing
but it would represent
an investment
in maintaining peace
that would be much much smaller
than the costs of failing to maintain
the peace unless
you believe that the united states
should simply
retreat from the alliances in asia that
we have created since since the end of
the second world war
and tell
our erstwhile friends that they are now
on their own
i know that may be attractive in
principle to some people of a
libertarian cast of mind i think in
practice
you would not like the world
that that act or anything like it would
create i realize that that principle is
not on the table but i suspect
the idea that it's always presumptively
unreasonable for the united states to
take a forward leaning position in the
world
is part of the mindset of many of the
people who have already cast one vote
and are about to cast a second one
and i'd ask you
to interrogate that proposition
to ask yourself
in reality
is it always the case
that creating alliances including
alliances we are whether we where we are
bound either legally or morally to come
to the aid of other nations
is necessarily a bad thing all things
considered
my answer to that proposition
is no
it isn't i think the world today is
better because of some fundamental
decisions that the united states made in
the wake of world war ii that we were
not going to do
what we did after world war one
namely say okay the war's over let us
come home lock stock and barrel
and yes we'll be active in the
diplomatic sphere
but
we will send a signal to the rest of the
world that you're on its own and if
there's some big bad guys
you're going to have to do the best you
can without us
i do not think that that is a strategy
that will make for a better or a more
peaceful world
all things considered
i have a minute left but i think i have
said what i have to say and so i yield
back the balance of my time okay thank
you
would you like to take the podium uh
peter i'll just okay okay an invasion of
taiwan would leave china politically
isolated economically damaged
reputationally crippled
and ironically if the attack fails it
would probably bring down the xi
government if not the entire government
of the prc and ironically clear the way
for taiwan to declare its independence
there is simply no risk gain calculation
that says china will attack taiwan and
therefore
no need to risk the idea of whatever we
consider deterrence slipping over into
provocation
my great fear is that there are people
in the united states and this is not
including professor galston who's given
a very rational argument but people in
the united states now
that are trying to prepare the way for a
bench clearing eagle versus dragon
situation
if not for the kinetics of it but simply
to incur an arms race that will profit
people and through that i fear that even
rational arguments for deterrence as
we've heard tonight
are feeding the fire that will
ultimately
risk our
conclusions in asia that we don't dare
think of
i yield the rest of my time to either
questions or to wrap up the presentation
okay they both yield their time and it's
time to reopen the voting jane uh
yes no undecided on the resolution the
us should use its military power to
deter china from invading taiwan the the
uh the resolution uh yes china uh should
use its military power to deter china
from from invading taiwan it picked up
17
of the vote you went from yes 25
to 42 percent of bill so that's 17
pickup in the vote that's the number to
beat uh
peter you picked up votes but not quite
as many went from 40 to 41
so uh the resolution carries bill
galston carries the day and here is your
uh
no no no
that that was a dressing roll because i
shouldn't do well
[Music]